Pat Verducci, Writing Coach, Teacher and
Mentor:This exercise is actually really helpful
and what I ask them to do is to sit down
and imagine their character is in a room
with someone else in the movie that they trust.
Film Courage:
How much easier is it for the writer if they
know from the beginning what the character wants?
Pat: A million times easier, it's a million
times easier if you kind of know what the
character wants. But there's always a starting
point. You think they know what they want at
the beginning and you start writing with that
and then it can shift and so I think it's the
most important thing. Like I said earlier, when
I do consultations with people it's the singular
most popular problem in the script is what do they
want, how are they trying to get it, what are they
doing to try to get it, how does that make them
face something in themselves and how do they grow
and do they finally get this thing or do
they get it in a way that they didn't expect?
I always try to start out like what do they want
because I’ve learned over the years like I need to
know what that is because that's the engine
that drives their actions through the story
and when I don't know that and I start to write
I'm just kind of like just driving over here,
I'm driving over here. I don't know it and it
just ends up being I throw out a lot of pages
so I think you can start like what is their
emotional need do they want love do they want
revenge what is it that's driving them and then
what's the specific thing they think is gonna get
is gonna satisfy that need and how do they pursue
that and you may start with that and you may shift
it as you start to write you realize oh that's
not what they want at all they want this other
thing so then you're gonna have to go back
and kind of reverse engineer what you did but
it's okay that's the process and a lot of times
characters goals shift in the movie like in
get out which is a great movie Chris he wants
to go impress her family in the middle of the
in the middle of the movie his goal shifts to like
I need to get out of here they're gonna hijack my
body and my brain right so so that that shifts in
in the story but but that's good that's okay but
he still has a goal throughout that drives him
and you've said before that sometimes when you
sit down to write that your character sometimes
starts to tell you what they want in a sense yeah
I just had an experience with this barf thing that
I did this thing that I just vomited out like I'm
just gonna write right right and I was just like
I kind of had the plot in my head because again
this side the left side is so dominant in my brain
and I was just like okay this is when this happens
and then suddenly she's in the middle of the scene
and like there's a flashback where somebody's
she's curled up in a ball in the bathroom
and someone's throwing movie magazines at her
from the 1940s and I was like then I went back
into the scene I'm like well that just happened I
don't know what happened to her but something
happened to her and then I kept writing
and then again when I went back that was
where all that whole backstory is what
the whole thing is really about
why she's doing what she's doing
what she's gonna have to face in the story but
that was never in my brain that that would ever
happen I would that there were that flashback was
just going to pop up in the middle of my writing
but it was great they she started talking to me
she started telling me stuff that happened to her
and I was like okay what if we can't figure
out what the character wants oh wow yeah
what if you can't figure out what the character
wants again a very common issue right some
strategies that you might do to try to figure
out what the character wants is to figure out
what they're afraid of what are they afraid of
like what are they scared of and what do they want
that's in contrast to that does the could their
want come from wanting the opposite of that fear
do what I mean if they're afraid let's say they
were had a traumatic past or traumatic childhood
could they really want just the perfect family
could you start from fear and generate a want
as the opposite of that that's one way to
kind of try to generate some ideas about
what your character could want one thing that
I often do with my clients and my students is
I have them write a monologue and monologues in
movies are we're not supposed to write monologues
it's one of the rules but what this exercise is
actually really helpful and what I ask them to do
is to sit down and imagine their character
is in a room with someone else in the movie
that they trust another character that
they trust and that other character says
what do you want and this character
tells that other character what they want
and I ask the writers to use all their five
senses to describe this dream that they have
and just to allow that character to talk to
the writer and describe what they want with no
preconceptions and usually out of and I say write
for five minutes and don't stop so just stream of
consciousness I want this and somewhere in there
is the is a kernel of something that they can
actually grab onto and hold on to so again giving
an invitation to your character to speak to you
about what they want so if they don't know what
the character wants it doesn't necessarily mean
they need to abandon it that that character is not
really connecting with them no okay no it's just
that they don't know yet they have to listen they
aren't listening they're trying to like put things
on the character if you step into the character
and let them talk they will tell you things
so let them tell someone else in the movie
what they want what are the ways a writer
can create stakes for their character oh great
question so obviously stakes are really important
for characters because they create suspense and
tension around the goal right so if they don't
achieve what they want to achieve something
terrible will happen they will lose something
there Linda Seger wrote this really great book
called how to make a good script great it's not
just for rewriting you can use it to write
a first draft but she actually has a really
great chapter on stakes and what she came up
with is a list of what is a list of stakes for
any human being and I'm going to try to remember
off the top of my head but it's like survival
love and belonging security security the
aesthetic which is a sense of order control
self-actualization which is self-expression so
the loss of any one of these things on this list
is devastating for a human right survival
physical survival oh my god I'm dead right
love and belonging if we don't have love
and belonging we're basically dead safety
and security we also need that if we don't have it
it's going to be bad right so all of these stakes
one way to think about that is to look at her list
and I think it's online somewhere if people want
to check it out but but look at that list and and
think about it in relation to my character's goal
if they don't like for example if I don't
make that person love me what will I lose love
which ones on this list am I gonna lose and if
you if you watch a lot of movies and you think
about this and you think about the stakes that
the writers have set up for their main characters
usually it's everything on that list except
for one or two things they stack the stakes
for the main character so it's just not love and
belonging it's also safety and security it's also
self-actualization it's actually maybe later
in the movie something happens where now it's
survival I'm gonna die they pile on the stakes
and every good writer has to be able to articulate
what the character's gonna lose if they don't get
what they want again everything is connected to
the character and their goal so if they don't
get this thing what will be lost and the more
you can stack those stakes for your character the
more tension and suspense and kind of like we're
just gonna be like oh no they're not gonna if
they it's just gonna create in the audience this
like connection and fear that they're not going to
get what they want which is what you want in the
story so just like the is that Maslow's hierarchy
of needs yeah so I think at the at the very bottom
of it or area I'm trying to think if I flipped it
so self-actualization I think is is the last one
yes and then survive safety and survival yeah okay
and Linda Seger created the screenwriting version
of that list nice yeah okay and so if you took
like a Jenga piece if we take one of those away
then that that's going to raise the stakes no
matter what it is yeah okay yeah interesting yeah
like like I was thinking about the movie coco the
Pixar movie Coco about the little kid Miguel who
has to go to the land of the dead so he can find
his ancestors so that he can become a musician
which is what he's meant to be right and I went
through Linda Seger's list of all those stakes
and he had everything except one and it that's
just good writing he's not just gonna physically
possibly die he's gonna lose his family he's gonna
lose safety he's gonna not be who he's meant to be
like everything like this kid is gonna it's gonna
be horrible if he doesn't achieve his goal and
so again the writer has to be able to understand
and articulate what's at stake for the character.
Do you always know what your character wants?